thank you
[Music]
all right uh let's see nick name this
song real quick you only have one second
here
uh back that
Back Back That Ass Up back that
who sings that no no one more time
can I get it one more time back to that
you know that song yeah yeah yeah I
think I think it's it's Akon
but sing it with the singers
[Music]
[Laughter]
everybody [ __ ] remembers Akon right
yeah yeah yeah like Akon's like when he
was no of Akon more I think from T-Pain
T-Pain put the Akon Legend in my brain
why do you call him a legend well cause
uh T-Pain I think there's like this like
little viral meme going around where
he's talking about how when he first got
discovered I forgot which record label
who's gonna give him like [ __ ]
however much million
and then he gets a phone call from Akon
and then it was like 100 Grand or some
[ __ ] like that and then he was like as a
viewer you're like bro it's [ __ ]
no-brainer dude like however many
millions versus like 100 Grand and he
goes but then Akon told them but if you
follow me I'll give you a career so he
won't be just like another product in my
shelf it's like I'll give you a career
and I was like oh damn it comes [ __ ]
dope so just because of that like Akon
was like legendized in my life I always
hear about how he helps everybody yeah
there's like a humanitarian stuff didn't
T-Pain end up like having massive money
problems in the future though possibly I
don't know allegedly I don't know he did
but teammate also was one of like the
Richer ones to have like made it out and
like still go to jail and all that stuff
but like still have hella money and I
feel like he has his hand in everything
he was saying writing entrepreneurial
like movies like his own moves that he
did yeah it wasn't like a label uh
Reliant thing but yeah you were it was
it put the songs really called what
you should
that being said I wish there was a lever
see you later and you're like yeah dude
I just was that an Austin Powers am I
tripping was it it's also in Japanese
prank shows yeah we're like drop into
the fire pit or something anyway see you
later dude he's a freaking Legend the
sharks with lasers yes Akon is a legend
he was so legendary uh that this was
just found out he was on a uh recent uh
radio show where he was uh approached
about a rumor that T-Pain had put out on
him alleging
that Akon's brother was used as a body
double when he was overbooked on shows I
heard about this and he confirmed it
yeah it's true that's genius cool and
they do that all the time they kind of
look Mercy really MF Doom did that all
the time oh that's tight who's MF do the
mask he has like the [ __ ] half he has
a Doctor Doom
I think that's slightly different though
when you're like like a a singer
performer it's like your [ __ ] face
there's no mask yeah does he sound the
same is that why they probably play a
thing though it's probably lip singing
to be completely honest he sings Back
that yeah yeah yeah because that's why
Nick got [ __ ] Mandela effective
okay
he went to one of the B-side concerts
yeah and I was like yeah it comes up
that good life
that's that's how his parents named Akon
and Beacon they talked about this on
like The Breakfast Club or something
right or something like that
um the morning about any other competing
shows thanks man yeah yeah yeah love
their show but see I'm now that this now
that this has come out I wonder if other
fans are gonna talk about life oh yeah I
did see him five years ago and he was
kind of whack I wonder if that's gonna
happen now well I would also Imagine
like uh at that time because he was
talking about uh literally said that he
had so many show offers coming in during
the peak of his career as a performer
that he could not leave all this money
on the table right like imagine
um shows that are random like I don't
know [ __ ] a corporate job you know
doing a gig for some sort of like
industrial yeah opening for for you know
a giant or the 10-year anniversary or
some Mega commercial blah blah like you
don't actually care nor are all the
participants that really know who you
they like maybe know your music from top
40 radio they don't actually know what
you look like I'm imagining a bunch of
like corporate like white people if it's
not a ticketed event he's like wearing
sunglasses and you're just kind of like
no that's for sure him yeah but it's
really just his brother that's true
that's you know what I'm saying like I
could see that it's hard to verify that
not one person in the county is going to
give a [ __ ] like even if one guy cared
that's kind of [ __ ] for him
right you guys this is really not Akon
I'm like hey God no it's him dude like
how do you verify that right
Akon is not about to come up is everyone
cool
but I bet some true Die Hard fans have a
feeling if they happen to see one of
like Akon's Brothers perform they'll be
like something's off better yeah
you have a passion for this
oh it's me
Colleen I'm sorry guys this is a this is
a terrible photo it does look important
we had to put it on speaker next time
yeah new rule obviously this is uh
pixelated but like this is what this is
what some people are seeing whoa
pixelated but it is a look-alike brother
right
I don't know you tell me it comes on the
right is he yeah yeah
like Akon
that's definitely [ __ ] up for a
ticketed event imagine showing up and
he's just like and his brother's just
like dripping right just like like all
the [ __ ] bling wearing sunglasses
what are you gonna say nothing I have my
own version of this so I what through my
through my not really but like yeah
people go to classic it's not really big
at the gym I grappled with them I swear
somebody just puts on [ __ ]
cauliflower ears about people there's
this there's my my Taiwanese counterpart
his name is Kenny he's one of my best
buds I've known him for like 10 years
we've all trained together but for no
matter what gym we go to
because we've been through all our gym
Journeys together everybody always calls
me Kenny everyone always calls okay yeah
I could see that really yeah to this day
even at school at this at The Glass
House for each other I know but people
still like confuse us with with Nick and
Kenny because we're just too [ __ ]
Asian dudes
it's kind of [ __ ] up so it's a racial
issue it's a racial so have you ever has
you have you ever taught one of Kenny's
classes in can you tell me your classes
yeah it happened the other day on
Thursday grappled each other and just
lost track of Who's Who sometimes that
happens
like you go home to the wrong house
oh [ __ ] I'm Nick holy [ __ ] it's a new
reality show some Wife Swap yeah one of
the one of the little girls came up to
us and she's known us for years and she
goes I can't tell the difference between
between both you guys that's what she
said to us she's like she's like hey no
she's like
sorry she goes you guys look the same I
don't know which one's which that's what
she said and she's noticed she's just
nagging dude
what's funny is uh they actually Akon
and his brother also have another
brother an older brother Omar who isn't
as much of a look-alike and wanted to
get in on the action but uh since he was
as much a little I couldn't do it so he
did it without getting Akon's permission
oh [ __ ] so it literally said Omar he
would do it without getting permission
from me Norbu Omar would be in another
country another city getting money and
I'd be like what they booked me already
but basically he's on stage singing that
that yeah
[Laughter]
it's funny because when MF MF Doom did
that same thing and when he got caught
he uh he told the fans that it was
always meant to be about the music so
you're wrong for wanting it to be me
he's like it's not supposed to be me
it's just my music yeah and that [ __ ]
expert gaslighting expert gaslighting
yeah that's kind of tight though but
then would you guys feel offended if you
went to see dead mouse it was just some
other guy I actually went to a show like
that so I went to a one of those hard
festivals and then it was at the shrine
and uh one of my buddies older brothers
super into like the DJ Scene so he would
get like these secret shows that are
like at mansions and stuff all the time
and he was like Hey so word on the
street is Daft Punk is gonna show up and
then everyone like all of her friends
were like what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
serious this is [ __ ] crazy so
everyone's tripping out like dude okay
so we got to set the main stage because
that wants to show up and this is like I
think uh pre Coachella where they
haven't performed for like another like
10 15 years so all of us are just like
oh so excited and then Daft Punk shows
up and he starts playing and of course
the Crowd Goes insane right and then my
friend's older brother was looking at
his laptop and he goes oh that's DJ am
actually because that's pretty cool yeah
he goes I recognize his laptop and he
has the same laptop everywhere he goes
That's arguably just as cool though yeah
and then he was like that's not Daft
Punk nobody thought Daft Punk is two
people so maybe one guy can't rep two
people well I think at that time they're
so legendary if you even got one of them
you're so happy oh yeah you know what I
mean so it's just one guy with like I
think the gold helmet guy came out and
everyone's like oh [ __ ] that's pretty
and then but my friend's older brother
was like I think that's DJ rest in peace
rest in peace am yeah you don't be the
sickest [ __ ] thing is if you went to
go see Daft Punk and um or not that fun
but if you went to see marshmallow and
dead mouse and they [ __ ] took it off
and it was Daft Punk oh that'd be crazy
when they took it off they said
and then they take that off and it's
[ __ ] Michael Jackson Tupac
my head's this small now
this [ __ ] little thing that keep
getting smaller
and you can't even tell you're like I
would buy tickets to that show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]